hello guys and welcome back to jaegerist
in today's video we will be going
through the story of kamado tanjaro the
demon slayer
tanjiro grew up on a mountain along with
his younger siblings and parents as the
eldest son of the kamado family at some
point in his life his father tanjuro
kamado passed away due to his illness
which led to his siblings treating him
as a father figure during the taisho
period tanjura lives a modest yet
blissful life on the mountains with his
family consisting of his mother and five
younger brothers and sisters on a snowy
morning dangerous prepares to leave for
the nearby town and sell charcoal in
preparation for the new year however his
younger sister hanako kamado and brother
shigeru kamado hold him back begging for
him to bring them along her mother
intercepts and tells them how tangiero
wouldn't be able to carry them if they
retired upon hearing his family's
conversation takio kamado also expresses
his disappointment and states how he was
initially hoping to cut wood with his
elder brother that day tangero bids
farewell and starts making for the town
he quickly encounters his sister nezuko
kamado who is carrying their youngest
brother rokuta kamado nezuko comments on
their siblings attachment to tangible
and sees him off upon arriving at the
town tajira holds friendly conversation
with the townsfolk and some ask for his
help to perform errands after spending
the afternoon of the town tangible
begins to make his way back home but is
suddenly stopped by a man named sabaro
saburo requests that the boy stay at his
house for the night and warns him the
dangers of the mountains although tantra
tries to deny the offer sabro continues
pushing and emphasizes that demons are
active during the night tangible finally
relents and listens to saburo talk about
the demons as he falls asleep when
tajiro makes his way back home the next
day he returns to see an unconscious and
wounded nezuko lying in the snow and
chilling rokuta with her arms devastated
he realizes that the entirety of his
family has been slaughtered except for
nezuko tangero picks her up and while
attempting to carry her to the nearest
doctor discovers that she has been
transformed into a demon and is promptly
attacked by her tangero struggles to
fend off his demon-turned sister and is
overwhelmed by her strength narrowly
managing to block her attack with the
handle of his hatchet as nezuko begins
to grow in size and overpower him
dangerous initially apologizes to his
family for the suffering they must have
felt during their last moments and begs
his sister to retain her humanity upon
hearing her brother's words nezuko
begins to cry the siblings are suddenly
interrupted by the arrival of giu
tamioka who attacks nezuko from behind
only for his attempt to fail when
tonjiro moves her out of the way
recovering quickly the swordsman asks
tonjiro why he protected the demon and
he desperately replies that the creature
is his sister looking at the madden
nezuko gio questions the statement
before swiftly removing the girl from
her brother's grip as tanjoro calls out
to nezuko in alarm gu tells him not to
move and states that it is his job to
kill demons he listens to tanjiro's
attempt to defend his sister and explain
their current predicament as tonjiro
expresses his confusion with nezuko's
transformation guillo comments that her
change is simple to explain any open
wound bathed in demon blood causes that
person to become a demon themselves thus
increasing their overall numbers tanjuro
exclaims that his sister hasn't eaten
any people but gear reminds him that she
had just attacked her previously and
bluntly tells him that there is no way
to cure a person once they are turned
into a demon estandro continues begging
for his sister's release gio brings his
sword up to nezuko's throat tangero then
bows before the swordsman and begs him
to spare his sister's life gio grows
angry and yells the tantro has no
authority over who lives or who dies
given he was too weak to protect even
his own family he labels all his talk
about finding a cure for his sister's
condition and his family's killer is
ridiculous as neither he nor the demon
lord would have any respect for such a
miserable display guild demands the
tanjore prove his dedication to
protecting his sister by drawing his axe
when tantaro hesitates upon hearing
these words giu silently encourages him
to find the resolve necessary to
accomplish all of the lofty goals he had
placed upon himself he then stabs nezuko
in the chest causing dangerous to throw
his stone at him in fury gew blocks the
stone with the hilt of his sword and
avoids another one of the projectiles as
tanjore charges at him empty-handed
seeing the attack attempt as only a
simple act of emotion the swordsman
angrily drives the hilt of his sword
into dangerous back knocking him out
staring down at the fallen boy giu
realizes his opponent's hatchet was
missing and looks up to see the weapon
spinning towards him through the air
narrowly dodging it he muses over
tanjo's clever strategy and realizes the
boy's plan was to feed him with the
flying hatchet after he was knocked out
distracted the swordsman is attacked by
nezuko and he dodges backward from her
kick cursing himself and kyu watches as
the girl reaches for her brother certain
that she was going to devour him to his
surprise she instead stands protectively
in front of his vulnerable body before
charging at him in rage gear recalls
tangero's previous statement that nezuko
wouldn't eat humans noting that somebody
a long time ago had said the same thing
and had been killed regardless he
reflects on the nature of demons in
particular the high amounts of stamina
lost during the transformation process
and what they do to alleviate the lost
stamina and prevent starvation eat
humans seeing that nezuko is not
following this example gear sheathes his
sword and incapacitates the unusual
demon with a bare-handed blow to the
neck while tanjiro and nezuko are
unconscious gio wraps the ladder in a
clean cloth and straps a bamboo
muzzle-like tube across her mouth when
dangerous wakes up after seeing a vision
of his deceased mother and siblings gio
instructs him to visit a man named
sekonji or rokodaki at sagiri mountain
and not to take his sister out in the
sun vanishing swiftly afterwards the
pair then leave their home and head
towards sagiri mountain later that day
tandro hides nezuko in a small cave
entrance and goes to the nearby farm to
buy a broken basket plus straw and
bamboo comically insisting on paying as
the owner was willing to give him the
materials for free reaching the cave
entrance tandro quickly assembles a
basket large enough to carry nezuko on
his back with a little help from her
shrinking abilities near sunset tandra
was told by a villager that to reach
sagiri mountain he would need to pass
through a perilous mountain where people
were disappearing unafraid he ignores
the warning and encounters a way station
with lights on immediately smelling
blood he goes inside to check in case
there were harm travelers but instead
encounters a demon feasting on three
humans he had just killed when the demon
notices them he senses something odd but
nevertheless jumps on tanjiro and tries
to strangle him nezuko avoids her
instinct to eat the human flesh in front
of her and kicks the demon's head off
saving her brother much to tanjuro's
shock as the body furiously attacks
nezuko tanjuro headbutts the head twice
in order to get an opening and pins him
to a tree nearby with half of the demon
restrained tundra goes to help nezuko by
tackling the body of the demon and
throwing it off a cliff although
tangerine nearly falls off as well
nezuko is able to catch him in time
despite the excruciating pain caused
from the destruction of his body the
demon does not die tantra realizes the
demon pinned in front of him smells
different than the one he sensed in
their house and concludes that his
family's murderer was somewhat different
estancia prepares to kill the demon with
his knife the hand of a figure wearing a
tengu mask touches his shoulder and
tells him he would be unable to end the
demon's life with such a blunt weapon
tangero questions the man on how to
properly kill a demon but he is told
that he would need to figure that out
himself the man's disappointment tundra
is too compassionate and overthinks
accidentally letting the demon perish
but the sun's first raised after
watching the demon's death tentura
notices the man is already giving a
proper burial to the demon's victims the
masked man introduces himself as sukonji
urokodaki and asks if tanjore was the
one giul spoke of in his letter to which
tanjiro confirms sakonji follows his
question by scolding donjero for his
inability to make quick decisions and
slaps him when he hesitates to reply
about what he would do if his sister
decided to consume human flesh sakonji
states the tantra lacks resolution
stressing that he must not allow his
sister to harm another human under any
circumstance else he should kill both
her and himself sakonji then tells
tanjiro to follow him saying that he
would be tested to see if he would fit
the role of a demon slayer on their path
dangerous while carrying nezuko on his
back feels short-winded rapidly sakonji
despite appearing to be much older than
him keeps an extremely fast pace with
his steps seemingly soundless glimpses
of tundra's past strike his mind as they
arrive at sakonji's house all worn out
tundra questions if he had passed the
test in which the kunji replies that the
test had just begun at that moment as
the two start ascending a mountain while
the pair scale the mountain tantrum
notices the thinness of the air and
thick fog covering their sight when they
reach the top tantro becomes dizzy and
feels weakness in his legs sakoji tells
him to climb down to the house at the
foot of the mountain by dawn vanishing
in the fog afterwards tanjiro confident
in his sense of smell easily begins
descending as he had memorized sekonji's
scent however he immediately encounters
several traps including tripwire
triggering rock throwers ramming wood
trunks and covered pits tanjiru notices
that he is running out of air quickly
due to the altitude of the mountain and
begins focusing on his breathing a
heavily exhausted and injured donjero
manages to reach the house before dawn
sukonji accepts him as a student after
janjaro wakes up sakonji explains his
profession as a cultivator as well as
how to join the demon slayer core
survive the final selection held at fuji
kasani mountain to prepare him for this
trial tsukonji begins to train tangiero
in the way of the sword focusing to
practice different skills a core
swordsman would have for endurance
tundra would make his way up and down
the mountain on a daily basis improving
his ability to evade traps and
sharpening his nose with sakonji slowly
increasing the danger levels of the
traps to the point where tanjore thought
his teacher wanted to kill him for
swordsmanship sukonji starts making him
perform the same endurance process as
before but instead wielding a katana as
a way for him to start thinking of it as
a part of his own body tanjuro stands at
the foot of the mountain and swings his
sword several times until he felt like
his arms would fall off next tandro
learns from tsukonji about the
intricacies of the weapon and the forces
behind it as he starts slashing bamboo
poles to train aiming and precision for
combat practice tanjiro learns how to
break his fall and get up quickly with
his katana as he spars with an unarmed
sikonji for breathing tangible learns
the proper forms of breathing receiving
blows to the stomach from his teacher
when he fails to get it right at some
point after the training begins nezuko
falls into an endless slumber deeply
worrying tanjiro sakonji attempts to
call a doctor but he is told that there
isn't anything wrong with her tanjiro
feels an uneasiness that when he wakes
up one day his sister would be dead he
keeps a journal which he writes in daily
to remember what he learns from sakonji
and also serve as something nezuko could
read once she wakes up finally after a
year passes sakonji tells tonjiro that
there is nothing left to teach him and
instructs him to prove himself by
working upon the basics he had been
taught he leads the boy to a giant
boulder and tells him that if you can
split it in half with his sword he would
be permitted to participate in the final
selection while tanjiro hesitates
overcome with doubt sukunji leaves
without a word his hand in the boy's
training completed dendro starts
training on his own harder and harder
for half a year but is still not
successful one day while thinking his
skills weren't enough tanjiro headbutts
the boulder in desperation a boy with a
fox mask appears on top of the boulder
and shouts at him to be silent a
surprise tanjiro notices that he
appeared out of nowhere and he did not
detect his smell the boy proceeds to
attack tonjiro with a wooden sword which
the ladder defends himself using the
hills of his sword despite wielding a
real sword dondero is overwhelmed by the
attacks and receives insults from the
boy who knocks him out after a short
fight a girl with a fox mask is present
next to tanjiro as he wakes up she asks
him if he was all right but tanjiro is
too impressed by the fox masked boy's
combat skills to respond the girl
proceeds to assure tanjiro that she
would watch over him and help him
improve his techniques she clarifies her
name as makomo and the boy's name is
sabido for the next few days makamo
spends time pointing out all the defects
and correcting the unnecessary movements
in tanjiro's techniques tanjiro comes to
know that makamo and sabido were not
siblings and they were raised by sakanji
along with other children humakumo
implies have been watching over tanjaro
as well she instructs tanjiro about the
concept of the total concentration
breathing technique by expanding his
lungs and bringing more air into his
bloodstream his temperature would shoot
up and his heartbeat would accelerate to
become as strong as a demon for six
months tundra uses what he learned with
makamo to spar against sabito but is
defeated many times one day a
longer-haired tanjuro faces sabito the
latter who finally wields a real sword
they performed the simplest contest the
faster blade would win for the first
time ever tantra's blade reaches
sabito's mask and splits it in half
revealing sabito's face he holds a sad
smile and fades away alongside makamo
after they disappear tanjiro realizes he
had not just split the mask but also the
boulder tanjiro is praised by tsukanji
while also being told that tsukanji
actually did not want him to participate
in the final selection let's seed risk
another one of his children being killed
tangible cries as they hug and takanji
urges him to come back alive sukhonjin
cuts sanjiro's hair and gives him a
white mask resembling a fox with the sun
symbol in the same place tundra had his
mark as a way to ward off evil while
leaving tangible tells sekanji to give
his best to makamo and sabito surprising
sakonji with the fact that his student
knew the names of his long-deceased
students tundra arrives at fuji kasani
mountain and gathers around with the
other contestants a young boy with black
hair and a young girl with white hair
and explained that demons hate wisteria
flowers which grow abundantly until this
area even out of season from this point
on there would be no more wisteria and
demons captured by the core roamed free
their trial is very straightforward
survive for seven days with
determination tanzero and the others
march ahead two demons immediately start
assaulting tanjiro but he quickly smells
the opening thread while avoiding their
advances and ceases the opportunity to
decapitate both in a single strike
sukhonji had bestowed upon tanjiro a
special sword called the nichiren blade
which at the decapitation of a demon
would crumble its corpse preventing it
from regenerating and effectively
killing it tangible smells a rotten
scent when praying for the souls of the
demons he had just killed advancing
closer to the center of the scent tundra
finds a fellow contestant running away
from a giant demon with several hands
swirled over its body the demon tries to
kill the contestant butandra pushes
himself to act and unleashes the water
breathing second form waterwheel saving
the boy the demon recognizes tanjiro as
an urokodaki student by his fox mask the
demon questions tangible regarding
current affairs to establish which
period of time he was in upon
discovering 47 years had passed since
his capture by the hands of sekanji
during his time in the demon slayer core
in the ido period the demon becomes
furious the condescend refutes such a
fact stating that no demon there should
be that old however the demon replies
that not only had he survived for so
long he had also killed 50 people in his
life including 13 students of tsukanji
referring to sabito and makamo as
notably strong victims and implying
tanjiro would be the fourteenth tanja
recalls to konji teaching him that the
strength level of a demon is
proportional to the number of humans it
had eaten tantrum notes his sense of
smell had developed to the point where
he can detect the strength level of a
demon by its decaying scent explaining
the rotten smell felt before as the
demon starts describing how it killed
both sabito and makamo tangiero starts
breathing heavily in an angry response
he charges at the demon slicing several
of his arms but is hit by a hook punch
on his rib cage and thrown in the nearby
tree hitting his head and fainting
tantro hears a call to awaken from one
of his deceased brothers while
unconscious regaining consciousness in
the nick of time before dodging the
demon's onslaught shortly retaliating
tanjiro cuts more arms from the demon
but realizes that no matter how many
arms he cut more would grow tanjuro
suddenly leaps very high in response to
smelling the demon's hands underground
while in midair the demon tries to take
advantage and strike him down butanjiro
uses an improvised headbutt in defense
rolling forwards and positioning himself
in range of the demon's head tantro uses
the water breathing first form water
surface splash and decapitates the demon
contrary to the demon's belief the
tangible would feel disdain towards its
existence the young swordsman feels
sorrow holding the hand of the demon
while his corpse crumbled praying for
god not to let it become a demon again
when it reincarnates tantrum thinks to
himself that all children trained under
secondary that perished could be at ease
now on the morning of the seventh day
tangero and three other contestants are
congratulated for having survived the
trial one fellow contestant seems aloof
another is still frightened about the
trial he had just passed and the last
one questions about when they would get
their official nichiren blades the two
children introduced the demon slayer
uniforms and the ranking system ranging
from the lowest to highest rank akasu
gagarasu is provided which would fulfill
the task of following the new demon
hunters at all times for communication
purposes and a crow lands on tonjero's
shoulder afterwards each survivor is
asked to choose an alloy for the
nichiren blade to be forged from some
time later tundra climbs down fujikasani
mountain his body in pain from the
fatigue he had sustained from the trial
and even the new uniform appearing too
heavy for him to carry tanjiro is
troubled by his emotions for not being
able to hold a conversation with any of
the demons before killing them and thus
losing the chance to ask about a way to
turn a demon back into a human a weary
grimy and bandage-covered donjero using
a stick as a crutch eventually arrives
back at sikonji's house as he makes his
way towards the entrance he suddenly
hears the front door being knocked down
from the inside nezuku walks out of the
house much to tanju a surprise of
awakening from her slumber tanjura tries
to reach her but falls to the ground out
of exhaustion nezuko immediately picks
him up and embraces him as tangible
starts crying out of relief in the
tenderness of the moment sakonji appears
and embraces them both weeping out of
happiness the tantro came back alive 15
days later tanjo sites at the entrance
of a house with a man with a large woven
hat with floral wind chimes hanging from
it covering his face the man tells
tanjiro that he is called haganezuka and
he had forged the blade which would be
used by tanjiro the young boy also
introduces himself inviting haganezuka
to come into the house and have some tea
but is ignored and the swordsman sits on
the ground unwrapping the nichiren blade
haganezuka explains to tonjero the
origins of the nichiren blade forging
tanjo still shows concern about
higanizuka being on the floor as his
belongings would get muddy but he is
again ignored higanizuka suddenly lifts
his head towards sanjiro revealing the
kyotoko mask he wore similar to
sakonji's mask once again azuka realizes
tanjiro had red hair and eyes he calls
him the child of burning crimson much to
tangier's confusion inside the house
higanizuka explains that the blade
changes color after being pulled from
the scabbard hinting that by tanjiro's
features he might finally see a blade
turning bright red chandra unsheathes
the sword and the blade turned to black
much to the frustration of higanizuka
tsukoji comments how he had never seen
the shade of black and taganizuka jumps
on tanjiro blaming him for not receiving
the chance to see a red blade in that
instant tangible's crow alerts him to go
on his first mission to hunt demons
after some time tanjiru equips himself
with a standard demon slayer uniform
under his checkerboard houry sukonji
explains to his people that the outfit
he was wearing was made from a special
kind of fiber the fabric is designed to
be breathable moisture repelling and
non-flammable it is strong enough to
withstand low level demon fangs and
talons as for tajira's nietzsche and
blade it is stated that not much is
known about its unique properties since
not many people have wielded black
swords however it is implied that few
black blade wielders have managed to
survive as long as others tangier
brushes it off since he is going to do
everything in his power to revert his
sister to a human again regardless of
what color blade he had to ease his
travels saconji gives tanjiro a large
custom-made box for nesco to rest during
the day the materials were handcrafted
out using extremely light wood called
cloud mist pine coated with rock lacquer
to reinforce the exterior and durability
dangerous expresses his gratitude to his
master and proceeds to instruct nezuko
to enter the box right before tangero
disembarks on his journey as a demon
slayer tsukoji straightens his people's
clothes and bids him farewell
upon sundown kazumi questions tanjiro if
they should rest for the night and
continue their search tomorrow the demon
slayer refutes stating that it is
because those creatures are active
during the night he can't afford to rest
tundra kneels closer to the ground
picking up a new scent at their current
location he speculates that the demon he
is looking for is somewhere nearby
tanjoro sprints past kazumi and towards
the source of the scent kazumi is
stunned by tangero's speed and soon
follows him but falls far behind tanju
yells out that a demon's at large before
jumping onto a nearby rooftop arriving
at the source of the scent tanjuro hops
off the roof and lands in an alleyway he
draws his sword readying himself for
battle tendril detects two different
scents a demon and a female human
despite the fact that no one was in
sight he could tell that the two were in
fact underground after finding the exact
spot where the demon scent is strongest
at chandra proceeds to thrust his blade
into the ground wounding the demon a
pocket swamp dimension opens up
revealing the girl trapped inside
tanjiro immediately sticks his hand into
the swamp grabs the unnamed girl and
pulls her out a demon's hand sticks out
from the ground holding a torn piece of
clothing from the unnamed girl's sleeve
the creature pulls his upper body out of
the swamp revealing himself to the demon
slayer tanjiro confirms that the swamp
demon is capable of using blood demon
art as the wound on the swamp demon's
arm rapidly heals dantero questions
where he was keeping the girl captive
the swamp demon does not answer instead
he grinds his teeth before sinking back
into the swamp kazumi arrives in time to
see the swamp demon disappear into the
ground tanjiro probably asks for kazumi
to hold the girl and for the both of
them to stay close to him for their
protection dangerous attempts to use the
scent of the demon to detect where it
was while he was able to pinpoint the
location and prepared to use the water
breathing fifth form blessed rain after
the drought he was surprised by the
emergence of three bodies of the swamp
demon switching to the water-breathing
eighth form waterfall basin tanjiro
manages to hit all three however none of
the wounds were fatal since he switched
forms as seen when he was only able to
cut off the arms of the swamp demon the
three bodies submerged once again
allowing him to jump back to kazumi's
side and regroup tangier was able to
wound at the shoulder of the demon swamp
again however the cut was again too
shallow tangible ventures to asakusa
tokyo for his second mission with the
demon slayer core the big city of tokyo
is new to the village boy he is to track
down a demon disturbance in the area but
early into his assignment tangerine
notices an all-too-familiar ascent he
frantically rushes to the crowded
streets and discovers muzan kibutsuji
masquerading as a human with a family to
escape the situation muzon transforms a
man into a demon and flees with his
family astangiro deals with the new
demon this gains the attention of lady
tameo and a young boy named yushiro they
dispel the situation and bring tanjiro
back to their secret house where tamiya
a demon doctor treats patients yushiro
is a demon as well and they're trying to
eliminate muzan tamio and tanjiro agree
to help manufacture a cure for demons by
studying nezuko's blood and the blood of
demons close to muzan lord muzan's
assassins interrupt the meeting claiming
to be members of the 12 kazuki and
unleash a furious assault on the house
using tamari and arrow spells in order
to stop the situation from escalating
tamiyo uses a spell that triggers
muzan's curse inside suzamaru the tamari
demon falls victim to the curse and dies
after the battle tanjuro ventures to the
south southeast where he encounters a
cowardly young man named zanitsu
agatsuma he is a fellow survivor from
the final selection and his sparrow asks
tanjiro to help keep him in line
together tanjiro and zanitsu venture up
a mountain where they find a mysterious
house they meet shoiki and taroko two
small childrens whose brother was
abducted and taken into the house
tanjiro and zanitsu head into the house
but are separated shortly after
tasked with protecting one of the
children each zenitsu accidentally
discovers another young demon slayer who
wears a borehide as a mask enosuke and
tanjiro come to blows with the suzumi
demon controlling the house while
zenitsu and shoichi are chased
throughout the house by the tongue demon
while asleep zenitsu showcases his
incredible thunderbreathing abilities at
the same time the wild boar shows off
his self-taught beast breathing
techniques against the horned demon
tanjiro and teruko locate kiyoshi and
learn the demons wish to eat him because
he possesses the rare marriage he blood
tantiro and kyogai come face to face
again in a battle where kyogai
constantly changes the orientation of
the room using his blood demon art
kyogai is also revealed to be a former
member of the 12 kazuki at first tangero
struggles due to the injuries he
sustained in asakusa after regaining his
spirit tundra is able to adapt to the
changes by changing the form of his own
water techniques he sees fit not to
trample on kyoga's writing and even
complements his blood demon art before
severing his head kyogai dies in peace
knowing his talents were acknowledged by
someone everyone regroups outside where
nosuke comes to blows with tanjuro and
zenitsu over nezuko's box inosuke tries
to slay the demon without understanding
the situation even though zenitsu is in
the same boat he tries his best to
protect the box for tonjiro chandra
mentioned earlier that this box was more
precious than his own life tanjuro and
dinosuke get into a ferocious
bare-knuckle brawl that ends in tanjuro
giving the wild boar a concussion with
his rock hard head the demon slayer and
the children go their separate ways and
the new trio recovers at the house with
the wisteria family crest there they get
to know each other and clash
personalities nezuko reveals herself and
zenitsu learns the truth about why
tanjiro is traveling with a demon for
the next mission the three are told to
go to natagumo mountain zenitsu is too
scared and stays behind though he later
ascends the mountain because he realized
tundra had brought nezuko with him
inosuke and tanjiro encountered mirada
who explains that he and other demon
slayers went up the mountain but
suddenly started all attacking each
other when they arrived then they got
attacked by the demon slayers who were
controlled by threads spawned by the
mother spider demon because some of the
puppets were still alive tanjiro and
enosuke started swinging them onto tree
branches to immobilize but not kill them
the mother spider demon decided they
were useless and snapped their necks
killing them enosuke used beast
breathing seventh form spatial awareness
to locate the demon the mother uses her
strongest puppet to attack tanjiro and
danasuke the puppet is already headless
so they cut it diagonally inosuke throws
tanjiro into the direction of the mother
spider demon to give him a boost tanjiro
intended to use his water breathing
first form but realized the demon was
not trying to defend herself so he
changed it to fifth form blessed reign
after the drought so that she will not
feel any pain as she dies the mother
even tells tanjiro there is one of the
12 kazuki on the mountain when tanjiro
and enosuke meet up again they see the
daughter spider demon she calls her
father and runs away the father spider
demon is very strong and quickly
overwhelms enosuke and tanjiro the demon
flings tangero away and he tells anosuke
not to die giu later kills the father
spider demon danju later encounters rui
when he lands rui was abusing the
daughter spider demon and tanjiro asked
him why he was doing it as they were
supposed to be allies rui told him that
they were family not just allies
dangiero denied it saying their bonds
were fake tanjiru is brought before the
hashira and put on trial for traveling
with his demon sister nezuko tanjiro
tries to explain the situation but the
hashira do not accept it all except for
giu who also broke the rules by
protecting nezuko the wind hashira
refutes tanjiro the most and even harms
nezuko for being a demon stabbing her
twice through her wooden box the master
of the mansion arrives and tell the
hashira to pardon the kamado siblings a
letter was sent from sakonji the
ex-water hashira explaining the
situation and asking the demon slayer
core to look past this even saying that
he and giu will also commit seppuku
ritualize suicide if nezuko harms humans
sanami tries to prove nezuko is an evil
demon by letting her out of the box then
baiting her with his own blood however
nezuko refuses to take the bait despite
her injuries and proves she won't harm
humans following the conclusion of the
trial shinobu brings dandruff and nezuko
to the butterfly mansion where nezito
and ninosuke are also healing their
wounds the hashira commence their
council with master kagaya while the
other demon slayers heal after their
injuries are sufficiently healed tanju
and the boys endure rehabilitation
training under the tutelage of aoi
kanzaki one of the nurses in the mansion
tanjuro also learns about shinobu's past
with a demon who killed her sister
tanjiro zenitsu and inosuke struggle
with training at first unable to beat
kaneo in any form or capacity eventually
the boys regain their stamina and master
total concentration constant the ability
to use breathing technique all day and
night long with their training complete
tangier's group heads west to join the
flame hashira meanwhile muzon dismantles
the lower moons and continues his scheme
to crush the demon slayer core after
enmu is assigned to kill tanjiru kamado
in order to become an upper moon and
obtain more of muzon's blood tanjiru
zenitsu and inosuke buy tickets for the
infinity train in search for kyojiro and
goku the flame hashira kyogiro informs
them that he was sent on a mission to
kill a demon suspected to be the cause
for multiple disappearances on the train
he informs tangero that unfortunately he
knows nothing of the hinokami kagura he
quickly senses a demon and kills it the
group impressed by his skills asks that
he makes them his and kyoujiro accepts
enmu enlists the help of five civilians
riding the train with severe insomnia
one of them is the train's conductor who
follows enmu in order to dream of his
late wife and child the group had
already touched enmu's blood by taking
hold of their tickets the conductor is
put to sleep as a reward for his work
and the remaining four are said to carry
out the rest of the plan as they sleep
the group fall into vivid dreams as an
effect of touching the tickets xenitsu
dreams of being on a date with nezuko
inosuke dreams of being a cave explorer
with tanjiro zenitsu and nezuko as his
animal minions meanwhile tangible dreams
of being back together with his family
enmu's minions work on connecting
themselves to the group's dreams through
a rope with a special spell that enables
them to penetrate the dreams of others
completing the second stage of enmu's
plan before kyojiro can have his
spiritual core destroyed which would
render him unable to move think or feel
thus becoming easy prey his body
unconsciously moves and he holds the
person connected to his dream by the
neck preventing any damage to his core
meanwhile tanjuro carries out his dream
while receiving more and more
unconscious cues from his mind such as
seeing nezuko's box or being told by
himself in his demon slayer uniform that
he is experiencing a dream at the same
time nezuku woke up and exits her box
before attempting to wake up tanjiro but
to no avail annoyed she headbutted
tanjuro but ended up splitting her head
and started bleeding due to tonjiro's
comically hard forehead she then uses
her blood demon art which engulfs his
reel and dream body in flames which
allowed him to slowly wake up and
retains back his sword in uniform enmu
continues using his blood demon art to
make tanzero fall asleep but keeps
waking him up from killing himself in
his dream tangible was able to behead
enmu using the water breathing tenth
form as sanchiro beheads enmu enemy
describes that this is not his actual
body but that he merged with the entire
train with it being his flesh and bones
dante were panicking immediately tries
to go back to the passengers to defend
them despite him stating that he can
only protect two carriages at best he
shouts kiyoduro and the others begging
them to wake up in order to defend the
passengers tanjore believes that the
weak spot is somewhere nearby and
requests enosuke to open the floor that
they are standing on the ladder gets
frustrated for being commanded around by
his subordinates and uses his beast
breathing technique towards the floor
tanjiro sees zenmu's neck bone and
immediately uses the water breathing in
order to behead him but the latter
protects his neck bone with flesh before
tandro's technique can make contact with
the vertebrae enmu unleashes his blood
demon art forcing tangero to fall asleep
constantly tanjuro quickly tells inosuke
to cut his own neck inside the dream in
order to wake up keeps on waking up and
falling asleep at one point he doesn't
know what his reality anymore and
positions the nichiren blade near his
neck ready to cut his own throat in the
real world before he could do so inosuke
quickly grabs sanjiro's wrist and drags
it towards the ground to stop him from
killing himself as anasuke falls towards
the engine of the train he uses his
beast breathing to cut away the flesh
that protects the neck bone for tanjuro
with neckbone exposed tanzer pleads to
his father tanjuro to help him defeat
enmu as he transitions between the water
breathing to the hinokami kagura with
that he uses the hinokami kagura clear
blue sky severing enmu's head truly
killing him kyojiro notices the tanjiro
is bleeding from the abdomen and tells
him to focus on his breathing in order
to heal himself upper moon 3 akaza
appears behind them akiza and kiyojiro
engage in a battle and tanjiru notes
that they are moving so fast he can't
follow them with his eyes only seeing
sparks in the process inosuke arrives
and tanjiro begins to get up wanting to
help the hashira out but kyojiro tells
him to stay where he is akasa and
kyojiro ferociously attack each other
and the dust disappears to reveal that
akuza has stuck his arm through
kyojiro's chest as the demon retreats
tantrum throws his sword at akasa
screaming at him not to run away from
the fight and calling him a coward
tanjiro lets out a final scream and
collapses to his knees crying kyogre
looks over at him and smiles telling
janjiro to come over to him so they can
have a final chat before he dies
thank you guys so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us we
will see you guys very soon in one of
our next videos